وفي خلص قالت الاداره العسكريه الاقليميه
في المدينه ان ثلاثه مدنيين قتلوا عصيب
اثنان في قصف روسيا استهدف المقاطع اضافه
ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت 27 قذيفه اصابت
مناطق سكنيه في المدينه مشيرة الى ان
القوات الروسيه قصفت المقاطعه 54 مره يوم
امس واكد بيان لاداره العسكريه ان القوات
الروسيه اطلقت نحو 440 قذيفه كما نفذت خمس
هجمات في جبهات متفرقه في خييرسون
ومن ناحيه ثانيه قال السلطات كالموالي
لروسيا ان مدنيا اصيب في القصف الاوكراني
على المدينه اشارت الى ان القصف
الاوكرانيه طال اربعه احياء سكنيه بينها
حياء كويبشكي
وكيفسكي وسط المدينه يوم امس وقالت
السلطات والمواليه لروسيا في المدينه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تستهدفت المنطقه 34 مره
باكثر من 170 قذيفه الحق اضرارا ماديه في
عدد من المباني السكنيه